(lively electronic music)
- Back in the old days,
this part of the world used to be
the economic superpower of the planet.
There were dynasties that
discovered everything
from the compass, to printing,
to making paper, to gunpowder.
They would lead huge
expeditions around the globe.
This was China, the Middle Kingdom,
and right next door, India.
This was the center of the
global economic universe.
But around the 1800s,
that started changing.
(photos click)
Over here, in Europe
and the United States,
there was a major revolution
that started taking place.
Science, then machines, then weapons,
trains, cars, flight, bombs,
factories, cities, and
with their new power,
these countries started to expand
to take over large swathes of the map.
China remained a great civilization,
but as the west started showing up,
knocking on China's door
with their big guns,
China couldn't really
match their firepower,
and they had to concede land to Britain,
which is how we got Hong Kong.
The industrial revolution
didn't really happen in China
the same way it did in the west,
and by the middle of the 1800s,
China began a massive decline
in its economic standing in the world.
A century later, that
situation got way worse
as China was invaded
by its neighbor, Japan.
China's economy was no longer
the prosperous Middle Kingdom,
but rather a shadow of itself,
a poor country that was
being occupied by outsiders.
Once World War II was over,
the west devised a new global
economic and financial system.
It was modeled after the economic system
that was working so well in the west,
capitalism, free enterprise,
still with some government oversight
and high taxes for the
rich and corporations,
but it was still capitalism,
and after the war, this
capitalism would go on
to become a miracle for many countries,
rebuilding Germany, France, Japan.
For many in the west,
post-World War II capitalism
was like a magic elixir
that was fixing everything.
It was working so well
that more and more
people started to believe
that we needed to get
government out of capitalism,
and let the market just do its thing.
One of the major advocates for this idea
of unfettered capitalism was this guy.
- There has never in history
been a more effective machine
for eliminating poverty
than the free enterprise
system and the free market.
- A Chicago-based economist
named Milton Friedman.
- If they fail, they bear the cost.
If they succeed, they get the benefit.
- The idea at the core of this financial
and economic system was that
companies would get investment
from people who owned
shares in that company,
we call this a corporation,
and that the sole purpose
of this corporation
was to make money for these
owners, or these shareholders.
In Milton Friedman's own words,
quote, "The social responsibility
"of a business is to increase profits."
That is the rule of a business.
Increasing short term
gains for shareholders
would benefit all of society,
according to this model.
And if you look at the data,
in the United States and the west,
Milton Friedman sort of had a point.
(horn honks)
And it led to huge prosperity in the west,
as the U.S. economy exploded.
Wait a minute, but what about China?
Aren't we talking about
China and its economy?
You know, the Middle Kingdom, China.
So, while the U.S. and
western economies are thriving
because of this corporate
free market capitalism
that was taking over the world,
China was descending further
and further into decline.
Instead of joining the capitalism party
that the west was spreading
throughout the world, China resisted,
turning to a one-party-rule
communist system,
headed by this guy, Mao Zedong,
who destroyed any chance
of China's economy ever
joining the prosperity
happening around the world.
By the 1970s, China was a
place of widespread poverty.
The once prosperous kingdom
had reached rock bottom,
but that was all about to change.
(film projector clicks)
So it's the 1970s,
and this is China's new
leader, Deng Xiaoping.
He came into power hoping to turn around
this 150 years of humiliation in China,
the decline of China as a superpower.
Elsewhere in the region,
China's neighbors had economies
that joined the global economic party
that was happening in capitalism,
and they were thriving.
They saw immense economic miracles,
and pulled millions out of poverty.
Deng specifically went
on a visit to Singapore
early on in his term
where ethnic Chinese had
adopted the free market,
and they were thriving.
He felt inspired.
The Maoist economic doctrine
that had failed was over,
and it was time to see if China
could rebuild its economy,
experimenting with some
version of capitalism.
But he had to do this carefully
so as not to disrupt the one-party rule
that China had created,
so he decided to just focus
on one little village,
a sleepy village in southern China
of just around 30,000 people,
right across the border
from the British-controlled Hong Kong,
which, at the time, was thriving
because of its hardcore
capitalistic economy.
Deng Xiaoping designated this little town
as, quote, a special economic zone
where foreign companies could set up
and invest in a very
capitalistic free market.
Hong Kong would sort of act as a bridge
between western businesses
and this little gateway
into communist China.
It was still socialism,
but with some Chinese
capitalistic characteristics.
What happens next is arguably
the most mind-blowing economic miracle
ever to have taken place on planet Earth.
(lively electronic music)
This little, sleepy village
that was a special economic
zone in China exploded
from a little fishing village
with little more than
a few thousand people
and some rice paddies to a massive city
of over 10 million people.
The average income went from $1 a day
to over $30,000 a year.
This starts happening all over China,
and meanwhile, Milton Friedman's back
in the U.S., being like,
(lively orchestral music)
yep, told ya.
Soon, there were a bunch of
cities designated in China
for special economic activity,
or, basically, capitalism
in a socialist country,
and more and more foreign
companies flocked to China
for its cheap labor.
It became the world's factory.
China joined this trend
of other Asian economies,
and eventually passed them up
to become the second
largest economy on earth.
You can see this in a graph.
This year, Asia will actually
pass the rest of the world
in accounting for more
than 50% of global GDP.
It is a massive economic transformation,
and it explains why China
has become so powerful.
Okay, but wait,
this is a very wonderful
story about capitalism
and its ability to lift millions
of people out of poverty,
and to industrialize a
country seemingly overnight,
but there's another side to this coin
that we need to talk about.
(paper rustles)
I have two graphs I wanna show you.
They look like this.
Okay, let's look at this one first.
It's called the Elephant Graph.
Do you sorta see why?
(elephant trumpets)
Let's deconstruct this graph,
and try to understand what this says
about the past 30 years
of the rise of China.
On this axis is everyone on
earth ranked by their income,
grouped into percentiles,
so these people down here
make an income that is
the 10th percentile,
the lowest 10% in the world,
and then the 20th percentile,
and so on, and so on,
up to these people up here who
are the richest in the world.
They have an income that puts
them in the 90th percentile.
This axis here shows how much growth
and income these people have had
over the past 35 years,
basically during the heyday
of shareholder capitalism
and the rise of China.
So, you'll see how this
plays out in just a second.
Let's start plotting
how much income growth
each of these groups saw
over the past 35 years.
The bottom 10% saw their incomes grow
by around 75%, not bad.
These are people who live
in the poorest countries,
who make the lowest income in the world.
The 20-30% saw huge
growth in their income,
125% and more over the past 35 years.
This is like the new middle class in China
and other Asian countries
who saw huge income growth
due to globalization.
They did really well under this system.
But then, you start to get to the people
in the 50th, and 60th, and 70th,
and 80th percentile.
This is basically people who live
in the middle class in the west.
Their incomes have grown much slower,
sometimes under 50% over
the course of 35 years,
which is little over 1% a year,
not very much income growth,
and some of these people in the west
have seen their incomes shrink,
like the blue collar workers in Detroit
and the Rust Belt whose
jobs disappeared to China.
So, so far, you can sort of
see why this makes sense.
The people in China who benefited
from this mass industrialization
saw huge benefits,
and the people here in the United States
and in the west who saw
jobs go overseas to China
saw a way slower growth in their income.
But watch what happens next,
when we get to the groups of people
who are at the 99 percentile,
basically the richest 1% in the world,
and for this, I actually
have to stretch out the graph
to get us a little bit more granular.
These are the people
who have the highest incomes in the world.
Let's see how their income has grown
over the past 35 years.
You can see that their income has exploded
under this system.
They're seeing tripling of their income
in the past 35 years.
Now, a reminder that
this is 35 years of data
from every economy on earth.
This shows everyone on the planet.
So this gives us a view
of who are the winners
and the losers of this
shareholder capitalism
that has globalized to
Asia and around the world.
The top 1% of income earners
saw the biggest benefits from this system.
They are the ones who
disproportionately benefit
from shareholder capitalism
and the growth of globalization.
(soft electric piano music)
Okay, so that's my first graph.
It's the Elephant Graph.
It is a very useful way
to see one of the results
of this version of capitalism
and the growth of China.
The second graph looks like this.
This shows the amount of
CO2 emissions by country.
You've got Europe and the United States,
and then, up here, you've got China,
the world's largest emitter of CO2.
Like the Elephant Graph,
this graph combines loads of data
to show us that shareholder
capitalism focuses so much
on short term profits for shareholders
that it leaves out any consideration
for how this economic activity
affects the planet we live on
and our ability to live on it.
I know you've heard this message a bunch,
and if you're like me,
it is hard to not become sort of numb
to this impending crisis
that, we don't really
know what it looks like,
and it feels like there's
nothing we can do,
but we have to do
everything really quickly.
But let me just reiterate in my own words
that it is now a certain fact
that our global climate is changing
in such a way that it
will very likely lead
to immense shifts on our earth,
and our ability to live on our earth.
It's already happening, it
will continue to happen,
and all we can do now
is maybe put on the brakes a little bit.
Okay, let me just wrap this up,
and give you my final thought
on what this all means.
I'm not showing you all these graphs
because I'm just, like, a data nerd
who loves to look at graphs,
although I kind of am.
Sorry.
I'm showing you these graphs
because the story of the rise of China
is often a story of how
capitalism has pulled tens
and hundreds of millions out of poverty,
and it has, and that's amazing,
but these graphs give us a view
of what it has also
done, what this version
of capitalism also
incentivizes and results in.
If we're going to consider the effects
of this version of capitalism,
we have to look at all of its effects,
not just some of them.
So, what's the solution?
Is it socialism?
No, it's not.
It is simply a new version of capitalism,
a reframing of how we think
about business and globalization,
one that old Milton
Friedman would despise,
and one that more and more businesses
are actually realizing we must adopt.
The solution isn't to scrap
capitalism altogether,
but instead to expand it,
to not just focus on shareholders
and delivering them short term profits
as quickly and as efficiently as possible,
but to also focus on other people
who are affected by the business.
You can call these stakeholders.
This is like the customers,
and the suppliers,
and the employees, and the government,
and the overall economy, and the planet,
and, of course, shareholders.
This is called stakeholder capitalism,
and it's basically just an acknowledgment
that businesses that focus only on profits
for shareholders don't end
up benefiting everyone.
There are winners and losers.
It's not good for a huge
swathe of the population,
nor for the changing climate.
Oh, and by the way, this isn't
some fringe liberal idea.
Some of the biggest companies
here in the United States
like Walmart, Apple, JPMorgan,
have signed onto adopting
a new model of capitalism.
This is changing, and in
the next five to 10 years,
I believe we will see a new version
of how businesses interact in the economy.
So you're probably wondering,
listen, I clicked on a video
about the rise of China,
and we're ending here with
stakeholder capitalism.
The rise of China is
a story of capitalism,
a certain version of capitalism.
It's a story about how
capitalism can morph
and change depending on what
effects we want businesses
to play in our society.
If we want to produce
the most amount of wealth
in the most efficient way,
then the old shareholder model
actually really works well for that,
but if you want businesses
to benefit everyone,
including our children,
and our grandchildren,
and their ability to live on this planet,
then our capitalism needs
to pull in more priorities
than just prophets for shareholders.
- [Milton] What may be right for one stage
in the development of an economy
may not be right for another stage.
- [Reporter] The so-called
greenhouse effect
is created by carbon dioxide,
a colorless, odorless gas.
- So, I got to dig through a
lot of data for this video,
and I was able to partner
with the World Economic Forum,
which is a think tank that I respect.
They actually pioneered this idea
of stakeholder capitalism decades ago,
well before Apple and Walmart realized
that it was a good idea.
The head of the World Economic Forum
just launched a book
called literally "Stakeholder Capitalism."
It's an in-depth look at not only the rise
of Asia and China,
but also other major trends
that help us understand the need
to upgrade our capitalism.
The book is really good.
It's packed with useful
information and graphics.
It's easy to read and to comprehend.
I'm gonna put a link in the description
where you can learn more.
It is available for you to purchase now
if you want to get a deeper look
into the future of our economy.
Thank you, World Economic Forum,
for partnering with me on this video.
The Davos Summit happened this week,
and I'm really glad that I was able
to be a part of it.
So, hope you're all doing well,
having a good year so far, 2021.
There's a new president down the road,
and it's kind of exciting.
And I'll see you in the next one.